[موسيقى]
كنا نسعى لتحقيق حلم
السيارات الطائرة منذ أن
قاد الخيال العلمي لجيتسونز إلى الاعتقاد بأننا
سنمتلك هذه المركبات ،
لكن الأمر ليس كذلك في الحقيقة
[موسيقى] ، حيث
تشير الرسوم المتحركة إلى الإقلاع العمودي الكهربائي
والهبوط عبارة عن مركبة
تعمل بالطاقة الكهربائية يمكنها الإقلاع عن
الأرض عموديًا ثم الانتقال للأمام
إلى وجهة معينة ثم الهبوط
عموديًا أيضًا ، وهناك
عدد من الشركات في مراحل متقدمة
من إنشاء هذه المركبات ولكننا في
مكان ما بعيدًا
[  الموسيقى]
هناك عدد من الطرق التي
يمكن من خلالها تجريب رسوم المركبات الكهربائية هذه ، حيث يبدو أن معظم الطرق
في الوقت الحالي تركز على
وجود طيار فعلي لإنسان على
رأس القيادة ، لذلك يجب أن يتم اعتمادهم ،
يجب أن يصبحوا قانونيين.  من
الواضح أنه يجب أن يكون لديك اللوائح وكيف
سيطيرون إلى حيث سيطيرون من سيكون
المسؤول من سيكون
المسؤول عما إذا كانت المركبات
ستكون آمنة أم لا وهذا
ما يعيق هذه المركبات ،
إنه سؤال مثير للاهتمام.
حول كيفية تناسب رسوم المركبات الكهربائية مع
مشهد المدينة لأن المدن
مزدحمة للغاية بالفعل ، لذا فأين ستستخدم
معظم الناس الآن يقولون إنهم
سيعملون كخدمة سيارات أجرة ، لذا
الانتقال من طائرات الهليكوبتر الحالية ثم الانتقال
إلى مهبط طائرات الهليكوبتر لنقل  المطارات
تستخدم البنية التحتية الحالية في
المدن من أجل جعل هذه الأشياء
تعمل ،
لذا لديك بعض نقاط الضعف
أيضًا لأن نقاط البنية التحتية هذه
يتم استخدامها بالفعل بواسطة طائرات الهليكوبتر
والطائرات الأخرى ، وبالتالي عليك أن
تتلاءم بالفعل مع تلك  يجب أن
تتلاءم مع خطط رحلاتهم الجوية ،
ثم يتعين عليك أيضًا معرفة كيفية
فرض رسوم عليهم ، فلن يصل أي شخص إلى هذه النقطة
حتى الآن [
موسيقى] ،
فهناك حالة استخدام لهذه الأشياء
بالطبع ، ولكن إذا كنا  ستحل
محل مروحيات التكنولوجيا الحالية ،
وإذا كانت
للأثرياء فقط ، فربما لا نحتاج
إليها أيضًا لأنها لن تحقق
هذا النوع من التحول في
مجتمعنا الذي
وعدت به بعض الشركات جيدًا
راهن على عدم ظهور الشرور
لأنه سيحدث ، نحن
بالفعل على الطريق الصحيح لجعل
هذه الأشياء حقيقة.